Hallo, ich bin Luisa von ELO
Studios.
Willkommen im Kurs Technische Modezeichnung mit Adobe
Illustrator.
Ich vermittle euch heute Grundlagen der technischen
Modezeichnung mit dem Programm Adobe Illustrator und zeige
euch, wie man mit dem Programm umgeht bis zur eigenhändigen
Erstellung von einer einfachen technischen Modezeichnung.
Was dieser Kurs beinhaltet,
ich führe euch ein in die technische Modezeichnung und zeige
euch, was ist das überhaupt.
Ihr lernt Adobe Illustrator kennen,
also die Benutzoberfläche.
Ihr werdet lernen, wie man in dem Programm navigiert und ihr
lernt auch wichtige Werkzeuge und Bedienfelder kennen.
Ebenfalls werdet ihr eine erste technische Modezeichnung
erstellen, die Vorder und Rückansicht von einem Rock und das
Ganze dann auch formatieren und beschriften.